aloha reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna get into our
normal business in just one second
before we do that I wanted to give a
special thank you to today's video
sponsor and that is - lame guys how many
online accounts would you say you have
seven I know exactly how many that's
specific yes it is well greg has a few
but most of us we've got 10 20 probably
30 passwords a lot to remember a lot to
manage but not when you sign up for -
lame - lame is an identity management
service that allows you to safely store
your existing passwords and generate new
incredibly secure ones protected by your
master - lame password now you only got
to remember one and Aisling themselves
doesn't even know it choosing the same
password for all your online accounts
can be convenient but it's also pretty
unsafe especially with all the info
leaks these days on top of passwords -
land also lets you sync across multiple
devices and secure the credit card
information on their encrypted network -
lines basic password protection service
is free to sign up for but head on over
to - Lane comm slash real rejects and
not only will you be able to start
better protecting your passwords but you
also be able to take advantage of -
Lane's built-in VPN for maximum security
while surfing that's - Lane comm slash
real rejects get yourself a free 30-day
trial of - link premium to date people
safe out there I changed into a shirt
that's covered in water cat hair oh
that's a stunt in and of itself oh yeah
we're gonna watch how the cork accrues
stuntmen reactive at a great Hollywood
Stuntz number 4 let's get into this
police story master way of the Dragon
how did he not break his tailbone
that's what else on me as a sign hi
welcome back to stuntmen rates you yeah
here with a key to Silva like crowd I'm
gonna know these movies oh oh he made
that oh yeah he's also having to be in
things like I know Black Panther Captain
America Civil War he was Leonardo for
Michael Bay's ninja turtles I got to be
a transformer my five build stuff will
be really happy you mainly specialize in
fight scenes right I'm a big fight guy
grew up doing martial arts that's the
stuff that really like it's my fault
awesome I was jumping wheels on meals
I remember this off of that fighting
implying that in real life he could
actually get out it's like a hotel room
that way how did you and be out do this
if you want to learn stunts these are
the guys to watch this take the first
but how do you not break your ankles
then dude he's not trying to stick the
landing he's just using it to get enough
momentum to visit a student you know
he's in pain oh my god from stay on my
feet hurts so bad see this was like
forever change how I operate them the
rest of my life I'd be walking with a
cane for the rest for these guys it's a
really a throwaway joke Sam Oh Betty
legit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow you think we're under cranking the
footage a little definitely so under
cranking for those of you not heard the
term before most films playback at 24
frames per second but if you record it
at 22 frames per second then playing
back at 24
it moves slightly faster I like the fact
that he gets hurt it's okay to get hurt
and they play with that and they make
the comedy of that yeah he's not the
rocker Jason Statham it's fun because
you can see it you enjoy it you
appreciate so much more way you can see
it yeah I feel like with movie you're
supposed to be capturing an image
especially a story like a fight scene
capture the fight scene if you're not
gonna show the fight seems like over
it's not about like there's not a fight
scene then don't worry about it but like
if you're gonna put a fights in your
movie you need to show it these are the
best fight yeah
like the way they follow the action left
right left whoa because how much time
are you willing to spend on getting
accidentals you have to pay should look
like those experiences well you see it
in two minute or one second you follow
Jackie good it's not good you can do it
this
is kind of like a homage to Bruce versus
Chuck Norris yeah you know Bruce has to
loosen up and start playing to his
rhythm and change the rhythm of the
fight in order for it to work for the
chamber Bruce Lee directed is it true Oh
sounds that they make Bruce seem like
he's making aren't him that somebody
else is dub over him you serious yeah he
doesn't do that really really don't make
like yells and and screams and stuff but
it's never sounded like that
it always sounded goofy right actually
no he uses sound to displace people so
like you can faint somebody out with not
just movement but what that sounds like
a call yeah with your jab and you go ha
they react thinking that the jab is
coming because of the sound and now you
have an opening never thought about
using audio cues I start somebody off in
your swings so know that your your
reactions are faster mister you got hair
so yeah dude that was his play but then
they added the whoa really I did not
know that called Bruce Lee estate oh
that's when you completely get somebody
anger
once you have them in your rhythm you
start playing them like a nice little
instrument you think don't go for it
don't do it I'll kill you break and
here's the remorse consequences award
you could have taught Taekwondo at a
strip mall somewhere in the Midwest
that's a great fight
Oh dad that five Adani yet oh very paced
out he want to really give the feel of
what a real fight is really like it's a
game of chess it's different like yeah
we're about to do this about there's a
quick moment of beautiful chaos and then
boom we separate it's like okay that
didn't work this works let me try now
let me come back in if you can find a
way to tell that story of that fight
like that it's so fun to actually really
see that I mean those make the best
fight scenes when there's an actual
story right for how I guess not modern
the pacing the fight scene is the story
telling you this fight scene is very
modern
yes in fact it's better than most modern
by the endless i teleported all the way
we're here to my desk to let you guys
know that this video was sponsored by
Ray Khan they have a very special 15 a
discount come over ray khan's great or
at the end of this video just see nobody
seen you let me borrow this one our kids
yeah I mean the stasis is called it's
called a legend rise of mastery I love
you Mary oh really yeah the street come
at me bro I can look back the kicks the
wire how do you jump like that from the
crawling position you could tell this is
that double though yeah but the other
guy walks away
[Music]
those guys are also heard that they show
us and basically choreograph it right on
the spot and then film it immediately
yeah oh yeah that's great it's gonna
help him flip back it's called the Gooch
so they have the pick point is here
person taken hit are they the ones who's
like actually dealing with giving
themselves all the momentum they need a
lot of times yes so I'm already kind of
pre-loaded and I have to make it not
look like I'm trying to do a move or
anything like that just has to be full
taking the reaction and performing at
the same time watching all these janky
changes be very excited about next
week's video and that is the Jackie Chan
Olympics that's right watching this
channel for a little bit now you
probably see the other celebrity
Olympics that we've done we did that
Jackie's chance Jackie Chan were strong
have you been waiting for this since I
signed up for martial arts in the 9th
grade
claiming the title of on his jacket
absolutely when I was when I was in
ninth grade I used to wall run every day
during recess when's the last time you
called your uncle it's been old boys
they fight a war you know I like this
fight we fight tunes like this praise
back into came out this is a game
changer this reminded me that you
actually have to be inactive you have to
be a performant or to do stunts as well
it's not just being able to go out there
and hit the ground or roll ones you have
to be able to perform it like this
director somehow gets his actors to do
anything yeah and then this actor in
particular also will do anything yes
they just do not give a crap about the
personal safety or well-being or even
the public image or anything it's like
such true this is one of the most
disturbing movies
yeah it's so real winner takes you this
long everything it's real yes I love
that about it get tired what a great
shot to cut you also good filmmaking
yeah across-the-board the reason why I
love the fight the motherf in hell is
there are moments in control he isn't in
power and he's having to regain that
power back and quite easy through to get
to his objective that's good as Mike
really saw basic things they like
anybody can get yeah and one of those is
Karen movement basically if the
protagonist is walking forward so
they're winning if they're walking
backwards to lose it but this this scene
in particularly the cinema now really
hostile moving right
move right a little bit more damn this
is masterfully done to language but when
you spit on top of it yeah it's really
powerful so old boy was remade by Spike
Lee oh
it's a completely different kind but I I
was fine with it this this fight I mean
it's a really great fight seem it's
almost like a little Hollywood mouth
yeah but they're basically was a rent
yeah
they're missing the point of why the
first one didn't cut the original old
boy it's a one-er because it shows you
how much willpower the main character
has that he will push through the pain
and the desperation and exhaustion
because there's that intent and as a
purpose in the fight it's okay for you
to do that a lot of the times now we
just have it for ego oh you know you saw
that one during the point of
misunderstanding by having Josh Brolin
get stabbed at the end of the fight yes
because in the middle of the fight to
show your your willpower to get out if
it's over already
thanks bro that's not what it's supposed
to be I need to see the internal fight
he's not hurt now look he's totally not
her it's like whatever like this all
right stab in the back I get stabbed in
the back every Thursday kind of itchy
there's one critique I've heard of the
film that was already very to entice
people who saw the original to watch
Spike Lee's version but he's also -
faithful to the original to entice
people who didn't watch the original to
watch as Persia ah the remakes very bad
to me ask some questions anything like
that if all of mine Instagram is GX the
silbo yes DX or Silva and of course all
of you enjoy the show you know please
consider subscribing and please leave a
comment for any other cool fight scenes
I love finding some really obscure stuff
please let us know in the comments below
it's a great way to know what's back
there
gosh so many Jackie Chan was I think was
that
start commenting it cool guys you might
be wondering what I'm doing here in this
episode well you had two stuntmen on
today right well I've done my fair share
of stunts I pop in is there the
reference yeah oh yeah it's like a stunt
thing that's not why I'm here I'm here
to tell you guys about today's sponsor
race on monster ships for about half the
price of other premium headphones you
can get a pair of these and you don't
have weird plastic stems hanging out of
years and you didn't spend way too much
on them so they look cool that's the
first thing the second thing if you
don't like the black and blue guys you
can get different colors there's a whole
range of colors on these guys they're
also about the same qualities other
premium headphones about half the price
which is a talking point that Jake
almost took for me but I snatched a bag
did so huge thank you to them for
sponsoring this video and all you got to
do is go to buy rake on Comm slash
corridor crew and you'll get 15% off
your purchase
give yourself some phones and when you
make an account make sure you use dash
line help go to readapt lane no cops
less real rejects and is the code real
rejects save get free premium crowd
not a roundhouse kick at all oh there's
some great fights this was your episode
I ever sound like Hong Kong plus a warp
cinema episode I mean some classic
Jackie Chan ones are gorgeous the final
fight there you've seen who am i oh yeah
Oh am i fight the stunts there when he
slides down the build a building it does
switch in and out between him and I
think this stunt my name is Andy Andy
the long any long something like that
all the police stories I haven't seen
the last Police Story the old school
yeah they sort of one two three it was
super cop and Jackie Chan's first strike
I'll be the one with the ladder I don't
know which one I haven't seen all of
corridor throughs videos this is part
for stuntman reacting I've seen some of
the other ones in this set definitely
seems the most unified in terms of where
they're drawing the cinema from yeah
it's from well you and me III think
there's other fights from wheels on
meals that they can pull because you'll
Mew meow is one of the greatest acrobats
ever there's a fight in in wheels on
meals where he's like just flipping
around from chair to chair it's freakin
awesome it is so cool project a one and
two insanely great fights in there as
well they've kind of touched on it with
the old boy fight which is the
storytelling and being a performer and
that's to me what is often missing in a
lot of American fight scenes I kind of
felt like fallout sort of had it in the
bathroom fight it's a struggle to try to
for the heroes to try to beat the one
guy Henry Cavill and Tom Cruise yeah I
forget that performers name and I really
should know his name the Asian guy who's
like the real star that fight that fire
right there has some story elements to
it but I think Jackie Chan excelled in
if you break down the store the matrix
had stories within their fights as well
which are a little more apparent to pick
up on even in wheels on meals they're
referencing way of the Dragon of how
he's figured him out then way of the
Dragon you know Bruce Lee figures it out
pretty fast I'll be it that is one of
the original monumental fight scenes I
actually saw a video of it recently
where Chuck Norris was talking about
Bruce Lee contacting him saying
that he wanted to make a fight that
people will absolutely remember so
pretty much he made an okay movie I
think way to track okay even an okay
movie that was all revolved around
getting to this one gladiator fight you
know the Coliseum it's a beautiful fight
scene he saw Chuck Norris fight he was
friends with him and he pretty much said
I wanted to I want to make this one
fight that people will remember
I think wheels on meals really nails
down that thing of like two fighters
figuring each other out Jackie Chan
struggling you see certain moments where
Jackie Chan thinks he has the upper hand
is all without dialogue it's just in
body language facial expressions and of
course martial arts moves where he
thinks he has the upper hand he keeps
trying out the same moves that keeps
getting hit and then eventually he
figures them out and gets to a point
where he's just like all right I just
got treated it's like a sparring session
and have fun keep it loose and then
eventually he wins I think Jackie Chan's
the master at story in fight scenes and
I don't think anyone's top Tim we all go
for like the cool stuff grand I love
that [ __ ] to you so I thought it's not
like yeah that old boy fighting the
remakes fighting to me well that was not
better than the original yeah I like
that they brought up that distinction of
how a lot of times nowadays especially I
mean I hadn't even thought of it until
they touched on it is we see a lot of
really cool one take shots now or can be
I think kind of a flex in a way yeah
yeah yeah I think the daredevil one and
then season one totally great
storytelling in that fun cuz you're
watching him use his senses and stuff
like that and it's it's similar to that
what they point out about that original
boy fight is that it is all kind of
illustrating and especially with that
very simple binary of if we're moving
right it means he's kind of losing and
if you know he's pushing them back
moving left that means it's kind of
winning that's great and yeah so like
taking those and going okay here's why
this fight needed to be won take versus
you know you go to old boy this is a
cool add update or the remake it is a
cool adaptation of that fight it is a
cool spin on that fight but yeah
especially even with that little note
about the stab like it doesn't really
say anything the stab in that scene
versus the other scene and so I like
that not only do they go into the
physical aspect of wall how do they
achieve this stunt where was the wire
here but also what is the visual
language of a fight and how
changed over time you know this has
nothing to really do with the stunts
that old boy remake is pretty awful what
do you mean it is like watching a
made-for-tv animation but it's but it's
still ready to arc but I did feel like
what well man you're like hitting the
beats I guess that's a bummer
no it's like that it's not a movie that
you just willy-nilly remade no it's like
the I think that hallway fight has been
so popular eyes that you know people who
haven't seen the movie I've seen images
or that fight of itself so people are I
think or sometimes are know the pretense
that it's an action movie when it's not
that's really the only fight I remember
from that movie because the rest of it's
a it's a psychological torment of a
drama when I say the finale is
disturbing
it's not even disturbing like violent
yeah like gore it kind of haunted me is
that the extra now mister that directors
made a couple of other movie that's like
it's like a vengeance trilogy or
something like that
I was so like serve like it's a great
film but for me and like I don't know if
I want to watch the other ones if
they're all yeah like those those
filmmakers can get really really
hardcore yeah and then you get a
watered-down version with a spike Lee
remake they definitely pointed out
something to me I had a notice of how
wheels on meals is in as in tribute to
way of the Dragon I don't know which is
that one moment with the light going up
but I based off of the story context of
the fights it's why that idea it hasn't
been confirmed by the actors but it just
makes sense when you watch those movies
and the movies are in with Dwayne
Johnson and Jason Statham and Vin Diesel
yeah they have like you saw Jax about
the mathematics their fights and how
weak or not they can look at any given
moment yeah and I'm like oh my god
that's I believe it only because I've
seen the movies they never appear or two
down on there like Hobson Shaab was the
most I think I've ever seen a character
give it to either one of them and even
then it's not that much known or than
what they dish back you know but that's
such what made Jackie Chan's fights so
great he gets his ass handed to him for
so much of the fights that's had to do
or that old boyfriend it's not over
coming yeah winning against all odds or
the old boy yeah watching the exhaustion
and just like yeah somebody wrecked and
made me think of atomic blonde - in that
moment I thought that was a fight that
had a really at least I don't know if it
tells the story as well but it had a
really great grip on like man these
people are getting exhausted and this
fight is tough yeah you know and I think
a lot of fights especially nowadays they
communicate the bone-crunching quality
of a fight but not how physically tough
and demanding and how much energy it
takes you know cuz we are used to these
really jacked-up roided-out you know
superhero type action stars
I think stories within fights are really
missed even if it's not the exhausting
fact like yeah a Matrix Reloaded he has
a fight with the character Jet Li was
gonna play Sarah or they're hopping from
table the table they go through three
tables and it's not like it's an
exhaustion fight the first table it's
hand hand the second table its feet and
the third one neo starts fighting back
in his feet in it's like first season he
was just figuring him out in both fights
and like Mary and I'm copying and
reading the program and then the third
one he's like yeah now I was using hands
and feet and they're going toe-to-toe
now and that's what I mean my story it's
not like you like to crazy scientist arc
of a narrative by just watching him
learn anyway this video was great core
go true if you guys haven't seen their
channel we've been watching a few other
videos they're one of the best channels
around right now like I love these films
study channels I like watching those
channels that study a lot of
storytelling but you know watching the
art of production design the art of
visuals and such I think these guys take
it to a whole new level with a big
Hollywood effects and stunt work stuff
so thank you guys for in this video
together you guys subscribe to corner
crew subscribe for the real rejects
click that notification about that get
known if I have never got a video up and
don't forget to go to the link of the
description box
what's a call John it's - Lang comm
slash real rejects and to yourself the
promo code real rejects get yourself a
free trial of - lame premium today
people
and picture the day shot for Taylor
Bentley tbh forgot to add it on oh you
know why cuz Taylor hasn't got him back
to me in six months I don't think he
knows he's pledged I don't know where
you been Taylor you know I don't know
what I'm supposed to add to your
shoutouts anymore are you Taylor I don't
know what I can do for you but shout out
thank you so much for being part of our
patreon seriously it means a lot
just keep that car on file and you and I
or aces I'm a club